welcome to the presentation on
multiplying and dividing negative
numbers
let's get started so i think you're
going to find that multiplying and
dividing negative numbers are a lot
easier than it might look initially
you just have to remember a couple rules
and i'm going to teach probably in a
future lecture i'm actually going to
give you more intuition on on why these
rules work but first let me just talk to
teach you the basic rules
so the basic rules are
when you multiply two negative numbers
so let's say i had
negative 2
times
negative 2.
first you just look at each of the
numbers as if there was no negative sign
well you say well 2 times 2
that equals 4
and it turns out that if you have a
negative times a negative that that
equals a positive so let's write that
first rule down
a negative
times a negative
equals a positive
what if it was negative two
times positive two
well in this case let's first of all
look at the two numbers without signs we
know that two times two
is four
but here we have a negative times a
positive 2. and it turns out that when
you multiply a negative times a positive
you get a negative
so that's another rule
negative
times positive
is equal to negative
and what happens if you have
a positive two
times a negative two
i think you probably guessed this one
right as you can tell that these two are
pretty much the same thing by the uh
what is it i believe it's the the
transitive property
no no i think it's a communicative
property i have to remember that
but 2 times negative 2 this also equals
negative 4. so we have the final rule
that a positive
times a negative
also equals a negative
so you see here and actually these these
second two rules they're kind of the
same thing a negative times a positive
is a negative or positive times a
negative is negative you could you could
also say that as
when the signs are different and you
multiply the two numbers you get a
negative number and of course you
already know what happens when you have
a positive times a positive
well that's just a positive so let's
review negative times a negative is a
positive
a negative times a positive is a
negative a positive times a negative is
a negative and positive times each other
equals positives i think that last
little bit completely confused you
maybe i can simplify it for you
what if i just told you
if when you when you're multiplying and
they're the same signs
same signs
that gets you a positive result
and different signs
different signs
gets you a negative result
so that would be either a
let's say a
1 times 1 is equal to 1 or if i said
negative 1 times negative 1 is equal to
positive 1 as well or if i said 1 times
negative 1
is equal to negative 1
or negative 1 times 1 is equal to
negative 1. you see how in this the
bottom two problems i had two different
signs did positive one and negative one
and the top two problems this this one
right here both ones are positive and
this one right here both ones are
negative so let's do a bunch of problems
now and hopefully it'll it'll hit the
point home and and you also could try to
do all the practice problems and also
give the hints and give you what rules
to use so that that should help you as
well
so if i said
negative 4
times positive 3
well 4 times 3 is 12
and we have a negative and a positive so
different signs different signs mean
negative
so negative 4 times 3 is a negative 12.
that makes sense because we're
essentially saying what's negative 4
times itself 3 times so it's like
negative 4 plus negative 4 plus negative
4 which is negative 12 if you've seen
the video on adding and subtracting
negative numbers which you probably
should watch first
all right let's do another one what if i
said
minus 2
times -7 and you might want to pause the
video at any time to see if you know how
to do it and then restart it to see what
the answer is
well 2 times 7
is 14 and we have the same sign here so
it's a positive 14. normally you
wouldn't have to write the positive but
that makes it a little bit more explicit
and what if i had
let me think
9 times
negative 5
well 9 times 5 is 45
and once again the signs are different
so it's a negative
and then
finally what if i had
let me think of some good numbers
minus 6
times
minus 11. well 6 times 11
is 66
and then it's a negative a negative so
it's a positive
let me give you a trick problem what is
times
12.
well you might say that the signs are
different
but 0 is actually neither positive
nor negative and 0 times anything is
still 0. it doesn't matter if the thing
you multiply by is is a negative number
or a positive number zero times anything
is still zero
so let's see if we can apply these same
rules to division it actually turns out
that the same rules apply
if i have
nine divided by
negative three
well first we say well what's nine
divided by three well that's three
and they have different signs positive
nine
negative three
so different signs means a negative
nine divided by negative three is equal
to
negative three
what is
minus sixteen
divided by
eight
well once again 16 divided by 8 is 2
but the signs are different
negative 16 divided by positive 8
that equals
negative 2. remember different signs
will get you a negative result
what is minus
divided by
minus
well 54 divided by 6 is 9
and since both terms the divisor and the
dividend are both negative negative 54
and negative 6 it turns out that the
answer is positive remember same signs
result in a positive
quotient in this in this example we did
it before it was product
and let's do uh let's do one more
obviously zero divided by anything
is still
zero that's pretty straightforward and
of course you can't divide anything by
zero that that gives you that's
undefined
let's do
one more
what is i'm just gonna think of random
numbers
4 divided by negative 1 well 4 divided
by 1
is 4
but the signs are different
so it's negative 4.
i hope that helps now what i want you to
do is actually try as many of these uh
multiplying and dividing negative
numbers
as you can and you click on hints and
it'll remind you of which rule to use
and if you think about
if you and in in your own time you might
want to actually think about why these
rules apply and what it means to
multiply a negative number times a
positive number and even more
interesting what it means to multiply a
negative number times a negative number
but i think at this point hopefully you
are ready to uh to start doing some some
problems good luck